warring factions in libya may have
agreed to a ceasefire
but the scars from nearly a decade of
violence are everywhere
and a plan to hold nationwide elections
in just over a year
reached recently in tunis hangs in the
balance
implementing it will be the challenge of
the un's new envoy to libya
luckily nikolai maladenov who served as
one of europe's youngest foreign
ministers in bulgaria
is used to difficult assignments this is
him
talking to al jazeera about his last
post as the secretary general's special
coordinator in jerusalem
there is no middle east peace process i
don't think either the israeli or the
palestinian side
for various different reasons are in a
position to actually currently engage
in meaningful negotiations that role of
middle east envoy will now be filled by
a veteran norwegian diplomat
tor venisland once again the task will
be bringing palestinian and israelis
back to the negotiating table
in an attempt to revive the un's
long-stated goal of a two-state solution
it has taken months for secretary
general antonio guterres to fill the top
position in libya
due to conflicting concerns on the
security council
the united states in particular wanted
changes to the way the operation
is managed there the process highlights
the challenges in a country where the
stakes are high for international actors
as well as the local people
the complications of appointing special
representatives
sometimes is not directly linked
to their portfolio
other things are at play here russia has
accused the u.s of unnecessarily
delaying the appointment
while the u.s has accused russia of
violating the arms embargo
and fomenting violence but the security
council agrees on some things
the members of security council
reaffirmed their commitment
to the sovereignty independence
and territorial integrity and national
unity
of libya which brings us to the new
envoy's first
task enforcing a recent agreement to
remove all foreign forces from the
country by january
kristen salumi al jazeera the united
nations